qu'ils arrêtent car avant de refermer le
journal nous allons vous présenter
quelques images de mode je sais que vous
êtes directement concernés les
couturiers qui sont toujours en avance
d'une saison vous le savez affiche
depuis quelques jours les grandes
tendances de la mode automne hiver cette
année il y en a pour tous les goûts
certaines lignes sont floues m'a-t-on
dit d'autres sont plus près du corps
je vous laisse apprécier reportage de
yoba grégoire les images porte la griffe
de jean-marie lequertier et gilbert
usant plus d'impératifs dans le choix
des longueurs les couturiers nous font
passer par des hauts et des bas très bas
chez popy moreni court très court chez
dorothée bis long chez angelo tard
l'asie
et cours chez christian lacroix par
contre une tendance qui s'accentue plus
des pôles de débardeurs l'emmanchure
épouse le décolleté tout comme la manche
qui colle à la peau comme chez par
l'adie maintient également de la taille
haute et effet de corse léché fopits
moreni ou tablier du soir chez christian
lacroix
les carreaux sont de retour du jour chez
dorothée bis
du soir chez par l'adie avec l'effet de
jupons tutu qui donne un petit air de
french cancan
mais carreaux de rigueur chez issey
miyake on joue beaucoup les
transparences minijupe en guipure chez
dorothée bis transparence et fluidité
on vole chez par la nuit ou alors très
très coquine la transparence chez
dorothée mis les hivers tristan noir et
gris fini nous serons en couleurs
vitamines qui donne bonne mine orange
qui prend qu'il oui chez christian
lacroix
et puis pour commencer la vie celle de
mariée j'entends il vaut mieux l'avoir
en rose